- Okay.
So, I've been wanting to make
this video for a long time,
and I'm still not totally confident
that I have the exact
words that I want to say,
but I am pretty passionate
about this concept.
And I think there is sort of
a toxic narrative in the world
today, sort of an overprescribed
antidote to a crappy life.
And that is to follow your dreams.
Other iterations of this
can be land your dream job,
find your dream husband or dream wife,
live in your dream house.
This whole idea of following
your dreams sounds really good
and emotional, and it can get you excited.
And you might say, well, I'm
in a really crappy place.
And the idea of eventually
landing my dream job
gives me hope.
What's wrong with developing
a vision for my life
and chasing that vision with all my heart?
Well, there's a couple
of things wrong with it
because I think if you
follow that train of thought,
you might actually find
that you'll be less happy,
not more happy because you'll be focusing
on the wrong things.
I'm not saying it's completely useless.
There is something to be said
about say, landing your dream job.
What you do for a living does
take up a considerable portion
of your day.
And if you absolutely hate what you do,
then it's probably pretty
difficult to enjoy yourself
or for the experience of life
to be something pleasant,
something that you enjoy interacting with.
But at the same time
you've heard, I've heard,
and everyone on this
earth has heard stories
of people who are technically
living their dream job.
People who have made it,
people who are extremely
successful and are miserable,
and empty inside and they
maybe even kill themselves.
So, what's with that?
Where's the disconnect?
They probably followed their dreams,
but also neglected so many
aspects of their lives
that actually contribute
to their overall happiness.
And I can relate to this pretty heavily.
Ever since I was 12 years old,
I thought it would be so
cool to be a YouTuber.
And I made like 10 to 15
channels throughout my teen hood,
sketch comedy with my
friends, action movies.
I've even tried movie reviews.
So often I would fantasize
about the one day
where a video blew up,
and my channel will be just like lifted
off the ground.
And I wouldn't have to
scoop dog poop for a living,
or deliver mattresses
up 10 story buildings.
And I was like, "Oh,
I could be a YouTuber.
That would be so cool. I could
wake up whenever I wanted to.
I can make movies with my friends.
I could pour my heart
and soul into what I do
and actually enjoy it."
And it happened and I'm a YouTuber now,
and I have over a million
subscribers and that's incredible.
And it is incredible.
But one thing that I didn't
factor into my calculations
as a kid is that I would
be the exact same person
that I was before and
after landing my dream job,
or making it.
I'm the exact same person.
And the experience of what
it feels like to be me,
doesn't change regardless
of what I do for a living,
and any sort of tendency to
postpone my own happiness,
to wait for some day where
I'll figure it all out.
I can't be happy now.
Things aren't good enough yet.
I can't be happy about who I
am. I'm not good enough yet.
Those tendencies remained and yes,
I landed my dream job, but I
constantly find myself like,
"No, I haven't made it yet."
I haven't reached the next level yet.
I can't start dating people.
This isn't the best version of me yet.
The world hasn't seen who
I can actually become,
but it's poisonous.
This postponing your happiness is toxic.
And I feel like this,
"follow your dreams"
sentiment really fuels that.
It makes us forget that so much happiness
can be found in our present moment.
And I think it's so foolish
to sacrifice relationships
with your friends, your
family, your mental health,
your spiritual life, your physical health,
in the pursuit of following your dreams.
Finding that one thing
that truly makes you happy,
and makes everything make sense.
You're delegating responsibility
to some hypothetical.
You're letting go of
the reins of your life,
and the responsibility of
forging your own happiness
in life as it is.
And rather, you're just saying,
you're relinquishing control.
You're saying, "Ah, this version sucks.
I want the next version."
And I just think that's an endless game.
Unless you break that cycle early,
you can be hamster wheeling yourself like
that right into your grave.
So, rather than following your dreams,
why not make today your dreams
as cheesy as that sounds.
Why not make your average day something
that you really enjoy doing?
Why not repair the relationships
that are already in your life?
Why not spend more time with
the people that you care about?
Why not work on your
habits, work on your body,
develop a better
relationship with yourself.
Work on your mental health,
your physical health,
your spiritual health, and yes,
have hopes and dreams for the future.
Otherwise you're directionless,
but don't forget to keep one foot grounded
in the present moment and
stop to smell the roses
because life is a journey,
not a destination.
(laughs) All of these things.
It's so funny with like
"follow your dreams,"
and "life is a journey,
not a destination."
There's so many cliches.
It's like hard to figure out which ones
actually are good advice,
but I feel like there's
truths to all of them,
but none of them are absolute truths.
Your own happiness and fulfillment
in life is such a blend
of a multitude of factors.
But anyways, yeah, like
imagine for a second
that you are a horribly miserable person.
Maybe you don't have to imagine,
but imagine you are resentful
and you are anxious,
and you're restless and you're depressed.
And there's like the seed
of insecurity, of anxiety,
and of just pain at the
core of your existence.
Maybe that's you right now,
and I've absolutely been there.
And you feel this feeling,
this is the experience of being you.
This is what being you feels
like when there's no music
to drown you out. No TV
shows to distract you.
Now, if you bring this ball,
if you bring this soul
into a new job position,
that's technically on paper
or what you want to do
for a living, this experience
will still be there.
This feeling of being
you will still be there.
And the conditions of your
existence won't necessarily
change the nature of your existence.
If you want to change the
nature of your existence,
then you need to accept it.
You have to stop running from it.
And you have to listen to
it and give it air time,
and like figure out what
your insecurities are.
Work through them.
Maybe that's through
therapy, good friendships,
heart to hearts.
And maybe that is taking
care of your body.
And maybe that is having
more fulfilling hobbies.
Like it's so much to have
that feeling of being you,
something that is enjoyable and
free and happy and peaceful.
So, that's the important thing.
If you are miserable, work
on your misery directly,
accept it, figure out what
the actual feeling is,
and how you can resolve it.
I can almost guarantee
you that it's a lot deeper
than just what you do for a living,
or whatever condition that you're sort of
externalizing your problems onto.
Let's figure out what the
core of the issue is here,
and that way landing your dream job,
or following your dreams,
or making your dreams come
true will become a lot less
of a necessity.
You can find peace and fulfillment sooner
than you might think.
So, yeah.
I would love to hear your guys' thoughts
in the comments section below.
Not the description, the comment section.
Let me know one thing in your life
that is immediately fixable,
that would probably contribute
to your overall happiness.
Because I certainly know
there are several categories
in my own life that I need to work on,
especially just going outside.
I spend way too much time
inside the walls of my house.
So, I need to get outside more.
Let me know what you guys need
to do. That's all for today.
Thank you so much for watching.
This video does have a sponsor,
and that is Cuts, and
Cuts is cool with this.
They know that this is
more of a personal piece,
and I don't want to like pretend
that a Cuts shirt will change your life,
and do this whole ad spiel
with like low-fi behind it,
like I usually do.
But if you're in the
market for premium basics
that feel comfortable and
compliment your physique,
I really need to start working
on my physique a bit more,
then check out Cuts.
You know that I've been wearing them
in like the past 10 videos or so.
Honestly, my favorite shirt,
and I mean that with full sincerity.
If you were to catch me
in public at any point,
walking around, at a
coffee shop or wherever,
I'll probably be wearing a
Cuts shirt. So check them out.
The link will be in the description.
I think you guys get a discount too. Yeah.
You guys get 15% off if you use my link
in the description below, if
you just so happen to be like,
"Oh yeah, I could use
like one or two shirts
that I really like.
I'm willing to spend a little bit
of extra money on one or two shirts
that I really genuinely enjoy putting on."
Then I don't have any other
recommendations other than Cuts.
So, check out my link to get 15% off.
Thanks again to Cuts for
sponsoring this video.
Subscribe if you haven't already,
but I don't really care if you do.
I have enough subscribers,
but I would like it if
you liked the video,
because that does help the algorithm.
It helps get this video out there,
and who knows, someone might
really need this right now.
And this could give them a few ideas as
to how they could change their life.
So, that's all for today.
Thank you so much for watching,
and we'll catch you in the next video.